hey dr. Burke here I want to invite you
to a webinar series that I'm going to be
doing for the next four weeks it's a
series of webinars every Tuesday night
at 8 o'clock Eastern Standard Time
nutrient absorption midsection fat
anti-aging energy these are very general
titles but I'm going to be covering a
lot of information on the root cause
it's all about a cause and effect
relationships you know when you do
research and what prompted me to do this
is I was on the internet and I'm trying
to find some information on a health
condition and the first three pages are
all drug companies so I'm like you know
I have to do a seminar to show you
what's behind certain things the
definition of a symptom is an indicator
of something else
so symptoms are not the problem that
what is that something else that's what
I'm going to teach you cause and effect
relationship it's called the evaluation
that's why someone goes to a doctor is
to find out the reason for something but
they're not getting it so medicine has
become the management of symptoms so if
you're waiting some day from someone
else to make you healthy don't hold your
breath your best health insurance is the
knowledge of what I'm going to show you
because you need to know that a lot of
the stuff that's put out there is
incorrect so we're going to do a lot of
cleaning up of false information
supplying what's missing and give me the
correct sequence of how to create a
healthy body
so these seminars these webinars I'm
going to try to make them 30 minutes
they might go a little longer because
there's a lot of question-and-answer
this the the if you show up and watch
the webinars they're actually free but
if they're I am going to record them and
there will be a fee later if you want to
watch them later but at least you can go
on here and watch it and check it out so
I wanted to share this with you so sign
up today click down below and I will see
you inside